where I left off in the last video we
were saying well I have two dice like
you know where let's say we're playing
Monopoly two six-sided dice and I want
to say what's the probability that I get
a seven so when the when I add up the
the two rolls on the dice what's the
probability I get seven so I drew this
grid here and this grid essentially
represents all of the outcomes I could
get with the two dice where on the top
row that's the the outcomes on dice one
I could get a one two a three or four or
five or six and similarly for dice two
these are all the outcomes I could get
so each of these squares represent a
particular outcome of both dies
for example this square means that I got
a six on dice one and a six on dice -
right and of course what does that mean
that they added up to the ended up to
twelve all right and we could go through
all of them essentially we could take
the psalm of dice one dice two we can
say well what do they add up to well
this is two this is three four five six
seven and then this will be three it'll
go up let's see this will be three then
this will be four five six seven eight
this will be let's do all of them four
and just keeps going up five six seven
eight nine
this will four plus one this is five six
seven eight nine ten and I think these
you see a little interesting pattern
here right this this will be six seven
eight nine ten eleven and this is seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve so if I
said what's the probability of getting a
7 well that's all the squares that have
a 7 in them so let's see that is let me
see if I can use this this fill tool
because this could be interesting so
we're all the sevens of this one this
one this one this one this one that one
so what's the probability that I guess
is that it has actually turned out
pretty neat how that worked
what's the probably getting seven well
as we from our one of the original
definitions of probability we said well
what are the total number of equally let
me let me do it here probability of
seven what's the total number of equally
probable outcomes we have 36 outcomes
and they're all equally probable
there's 36 total outcomes and so what's
the probably get seven what how many of
these 36 outcomes I result in the dice
adding up to seven and once one two
three four five six so six so the
probability of getting a 7 is equal to 6
over 36 is equal to 1/6 and so we could
you know use this grid is useful for
figuring out the probability of getting
any number we could say and we can even
just just by looking at this we see that
the most likely of all of the numbers we
get is 7 right and if you just look at
the pattern because it covers this whole
diagonal in terms of and then you know
the probability of getting a 6 is equal
to the pub getting an 8
you know the probably go to 9 is equal
to the probability of getting a of the 9
is equal to a probability of getting a 5
and so forth and so on actually let's
let's do that let's say so 7 is the most
probable and just to get some intuition
on on dice rolls let's say what's the
the second light so what's our probably
giving 8 8 8 8 8 8 and so how many
eights are there out of a out of the
total number let's see so probability of
getting an 8 is equal to 1 2 3 4 5 is
equal to 5 over 36 and that's also equal
to the probability of 6 right 1 2 3 4 5
6 is probability of getting a 6 so let
me color the 6 is the same the same
green just so we know that that's a so
that's a 6 6 so those are all the sixes
and you know this actually wouldn't hurt
to memorize because when you play
Monopoly you'll know your odds you know
landing on boardwalk for example and
then you would have to uh you would you
would you know know what your well
actually I'll probably do another video
on what expected value and expected cost
and things like that because that's
probability plus a little bit of money
it'll be very useful when you're playing
Monopoly and so we could keep doing with
the probability of 5 plus 1 2 3 4
there's four out of the 36 outcomes over
5 so the probability of a 5 is
- 4 out of 36 and that is equal to 1
over 9 and that's also the same as
probability of getting a 9 probability 9
is equal 1 over 9 so that's interesting
I mean you know if you ever play craps
or we play Monopoly you now have a sense
of what the different probabilities are
of the different roles and you know
that's why I think in a lot of games you
know 7 is a very important role because
that is actually the most probable of
number for example that the probability
of getting a 7 is higher than the
probability of getting a 9 or a 5 right
because what's the probability of
getting what's the probability of of a 5
and we'll say or a 9 that you is an or
right well that's the probability of
getting a 5 plus the probability of
getting a 9 which is equal to 1/9 plus
sine 1/9 1/9 plus 1/9 which is equal to
2 ninths Oh actually I was wrong I see
that that's why it's good to do the
calculation 1/6 is less than 2 nights so
no this is a higher one but I can say so
I was wrong about that but we can say
that the probability of the probability
of getting a let's say a a 2 or 11 - or
an 11 is less than the probability of
getting a 7 and let's calculate that
what's the probably getting a 2 a 2
actually I should have said a 3 or 11 I
want it to be symmetric well let's just
go with what I wrote
probability of - there's only one
situation where I get a 2 right so this
is 1 over 36 one of the 36 results into
2 and then the 11 that's 2 out of 36
right so 2 out of 36 is 1 over 8 of 9 is
2 2 out of 36 and so that equals 3 over
36 and so that equals 1 over 12 so the
probability of getting a 2 which is just
this one or an 11 is 1 out of 12 while
the problem you're getting in so the
probably going to 7 is actually twice
that of getting a 2 or an 11 so that's
just interesting I know you know
sometimes I don't know where these going
but I think it's interesting to analyze
dice because dice show up a lot and
another way
although this agreed is probably the
clearest way of doing it another way if
that I do it if I don't have a grid in
front of me if I say we know what's the
probability of getting a I don't know
let's say what's the probability of
getting a 5 well it's the probability of
let's say this is dice 1 and this is
essentially the same thing as a grid but
it's good to have multiple frameworks of
of this so how can I get a 5 well if I
get a 1 on dice 1 I get a 2 I get a I
get here I get a 4 on dice two I get a 2
then I need a 3 if I get a 3 and I need
a 2 if I have a for that I need a 1 and
then if I have a and then if I have a 5
you know and then load those are the
only situations right so we could say
well what's the probability of getting
so this we need each of these
probabilities and then the next one has
to be these so there's four
probabilities that kind of keep us in
the game and dice one so what's the
probability of getting a one
well that's 1/6 so this is dice one this
is you go to this is a 3 this is you get
a 4 all right and so what's the
probability of getting a 1 on dice 1
that's 1 over 6 right now they're all 1
over 6 that's probability get a 2 that's
probably to get a 3 that's probably to
get a 4 right and so given that you got
a 1 on dice 1 what's the probability to
get a 4 then so then you know there's 6
problem you know this this tree and
there's you know you had a 5 or 6 but
those don't count because we'd be out of
the game so in dice 1 then on dice -
there's a 1 out of 6 chance that I get a
4 and then there's you know a bunch of
other chances for all the other numbers
but this is the only situation which we
get a 5 all right and similarly on dice
this is dice - this column and then if I
get a 2 what do I need on dice - I need
a 3 well to get exactly a 3 there's a
1/6 chance again and of course they sell
them up to 5 now have a 3 here then
there's a 1/6 chance that I get a 2
which is exactly what I need and of
course there's a lot of other things we
can get but we're selecting for the 5s
and if out of 4 I'm going to switch
colors there's a 1/6 chance that I get a
1 to get a 5
right so what are all the probabilities
of this well this is one six times once
so the probability of this of getting a
one and then a four let me clean this up
think I'm running out of time actually
let me do it on this side so the
probability of this event
these are messier than normal of this
one I'm getting a one and then getting a
four well that's one out of 36 right
one-sixth this is 1/6 times 1/6 this is
1/6 and then after that happens you have
to get another 1/6 so that's 1 out of 36
and by a similar logic this is 1 out of
36 this is 1 out of 36 and this is 1 out
of 36
each of these is 1 out of 36 and if you
think about that grid we drew each of
these outcomes represent the square on
that grid getting a 2 and then AG 3
getting a 1 and then getting in 4 and
then our total probably getting 5 is the
sum of all these four out of 36 which is
equal to 1 over 9 so I just want to show
you you don't have to draw a grid you
could do a tree you could do a little
table like this and say well what are
the ways I can get 5 and what's the
probability of each of these and then
sum them up and they all work and and in
different times different different
methods will be more useful I will see
you in the next video